oh we are live welcome to SRA your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel happy whever whatever you are
here in the UK the sun's come out it's
amazing I actually got sunburnt
yesterday I got a video going on
tomorrow and you're watching me nearly
die um it's so and I'm not joking watch
it tomorrow I nearly die so um we're
here with young Matthew or not young
Matthew because you had a birthday in
the week old fart Matthew old fart
Matthew welcome old for very very young
stormy look at him he's look like 12
years old a cheeky little CH 13 at the
most and uh elderly elderly Harris how
are you how is everybody doing well
doing good
awake that's the least we can ask for
and obviously we've got people in the
comments has normal marks with us Bob's
with us side quest is with us sci-fi
Quest and um Storm's with us stormy I
don't know don't get um and yeah and we
are ready to go so today we are going to
be talking about sci-fi and its
influence on real life a little
bit but I'm going to tell you why in a
minute but before that we'll obviously
say hello to everybody see how we're
doing and then um we'll crack on but I'm
going to run the credits if I can
remember how to do
it that
one
[Music]
never fast enough I try to run how are
we guys anyway how are we all
doing doing good doing well doing pretty
good half dead but half alive
too were you out last night young no I I
was streaming video games with with
sci-fi Quest was there with me for
literally 10 hours yesterday four hours
of trying to figure out technology and
six hours of actually
streaming well I know Matthew is trying
to think of some things to help you with
that to get your new G3 gaming channel
going yes so SAR you're with us K's with
us ah's with us kaha is one of my
favorite names because every time I see
I go
kaha is we're minutes late we're late
I'm sorry but I was faffing around it
was my fault um and we forgot to invite
storm in as well sure a little bit
oops so anyway I was watching another
YouTube channel the other day and they
were talking about Star Trek and one of
the people on the panel made the Bold
claim that without Star Trek that is
more than just art it is actually
culture um without Star Trek though we
would not have mobile phones technology
and and they meant it else on the panel
went don't be an idiot that's the
stupidest thing we've ever heard of in
our lives but he genuinely he genuinely
seemed to believe that so um John hey
Mark
K how are you Mark how you dling um I've
messaged you messaged me back Mark dang
you um but um so yeah so I I just was
wanted to talk about that psychology and
and stormmy we're going to be relying on
you quite a lot here so brain on ready
to go ready to go right so that first
statement
if it wasn't for Star Trek we wouldn't
have mobile
phones anybody want to jump on that
before well didn't we have landline
phones when we we definitely had
landline phones when Star Trek was was
airing no landline phones weren't
invented until the
1980s landline phones landline phones
were until the
1980s um noer gry and Bell had big like
thing and he leather jacket in one glove
I know that's Michael
Jackson oh no mo landline phones were
invented in like what was it storm was
like the 1850s or something uh it was
something like that yeah it was U 1876
because it was the phonogram first huh
or couple you've disappeared I know I
put a bunch of eye drops in and my my
eyes are dying I I thought it would help
me wake up and nope I just look like I'm
crying now so oh that we want to see
yeah right my point is Right landline
phones already existed so the concept of
a phone already existed Star Trek might
have had their communicators which was
like portable but the idea of having
portable devices has always been a thing
Star Trek didn't invent the idea of a
portable telephone they just used it in
their show well I don't I don't know are
we talking about just the portable cell
you know a cell phone like the Nokia
things that will Outlast human
civilization or we talk smartphones
there were I don't know if you guys
remember Omni Magazine from the 70s and
the 80s um but there were frequent
articles
about
um future
technologies that would
um develop into a tri a tricorder I
think the the biggest best analogy in
terms of like Star Trek and modern
technology is not necessarily
the phone part of the communicator part
I think it's the the all the things that
a tricorder can
do if you
remember way back probably to the 80s or
90s the first
um commercials AT&T did narrated by Tom
celic is like you know there's this guy
uh he calls his wife on his wrist phone
and um she says how is your day she said
he says it was great and he's out like
in yuse or someplace just gorgeous
mountain range well the the the phone
the the actual video phone that was
drawn on in um Dick Tracy Comics more
than 100 years ago yeah through the
little video screen and we've actually
got them now we can actually do it
through smartphones now which is crazy
it's just it's just insane and um can't
say that Dick Tracy invented the
we wouldn't have smart watches if it
wasn't for Tracy but you know there
anyway there's a been a lot of U lot of
Articles over the last 50 years about um
science fiction is always the
predecessor of where our technology is
going to be uh because the science
fiction guys they dream up all of these
remarkable things and somebody
eventually says oh that was a really
damn good
idea and they progressed from there I
mean even
um there was a children's book series
called Tom Swift not the TV series
series from you know going back to more
than 100 years and
um you know there there were all sorts
of crazy title Tom Swift and the
oceanograph
oceanographical accelerator or something
crazy in ition and if you read those
books as a kid you'll say oh those
things are kind of you know uh drone
torpedos or drone ships that swim under
the water now I mean all those things
are kind of coming true as our
technology goes forward and
um uh one of the guys that was
developing the Blackberry I think he
famously said that yeah the tricorder
was one of the primary
inspirations
of
um of the the Blackberry uh first phone
you know be able to send text messages
and even in the Apple patent for the uh
iPhone and iPad they use Stanley
Kubrick's
2001 as part of the idea because they
were using that technology in the film
so that is a documented documented um
use of art inspiring technology decades
later yeah you could actually argue that
Arthur C Clark invented the iPad because
that's what we store in 2001 Space
Odyssey was using it for like
Diagnostics and things like this yeah I
think Mark Cartier did have it a little
while who from obviously the shuttle pod
show um absolute Legend please go and
and find them and subscribe saying that
basically we would have mobile phones
but maybe we wouldn't have flip phones
and I mean the uh I did write his name
down uh Martin Cooper was the um head
and it was the director at Motorola
research and development um back when
they were trying to create the first of
their version phones and they looked at
all the different types of phone and he
he apparently he was like I want
something that looks a bit like that
Star Trek Communicator and that's
basically what that was their
inspiration for why they have that
design and and then they realized it was
really reliable it was way better than
they slip ups and things and all sorts
yeah so um it is obviously a nonsense to
say we wouldn't have mobile bones but
like you said
there sometimes this inspiration comes
from what what do you think
Matt yeah the art would definitely
Inspire the people who are creating the
technology
um I think that's a given uh science
fiction writers will
make all these weird Fantastical things
and then people in the future will go
well I'm working on a project
let's I'd quite like to make this from
this show they might already be working
on that project but they would be
inspired by something from the show or
from a book or from a movie or from
whatever it might be so art does
definitely Inspire but it doesn't U it
it's not the root cause of why it's
there so Harris is then like the next
little thing we got is the first step of
invention imagination then is that a
fair fair statement to make oh yeah uh
creativity has to be part of
inventiveness I would think it's just
kind of inherently part part of it right
yeah I mean obviously you got like
necessity that's
probably a big part of it they say
that's the mother but when you then
start thinking
about how to then create those things
yeah Harris did you get beat up by a
leprechaun I dropped in my entire face
just died on me for like 10 minutes what
the hell happened what did you what kind
of blunt did you hit I'm the back I
think he just got a glass full of eye
drop stuff and just
went face I did it on screen and I
didn't think it was gonna be that bad
and a freaking it wasn't ey drops it was
sulfuric acid yeah sounds about rain
couldn't
see I could barely see y'all when I came
back on
screen not laugh we're not laughing he's
killed himself
he God it looked like he just got beat
up like I don't know I guess that's what
three and a half hours of sleep and then
popping some eye drops in does do you
but K uh we did our little scientific
hypothesis right here um that was one
hell of a rough night don't do that
again he has his bless him
um I was going to say that that with
like um in science fiction writers and
things so obviously they're
imagining um the future they're trying
to think and it's is that like a natural
state that that's like always kind of
done that um actually back in 2010 26%
of all new books were Science Fiction
it's a it's a massively important it's
what people think about you know um is
it something we've always done do you
think is like think about the next day
when you could talk about relig and get
all sorts of very philosophical in this
if you wanted to but is that fair this
this this has been going on with Prout
history I mean who was it I think it's
like Michelangelo or something literally
Drew up sketches for a um propulsion
device a helicopter is what we know as a
helicopter now the submarine and he
didn't invent a helicopter someone else
invented it but he dreamt it up he
dreamed up the idea one day he drew it
and then obviously that gave inspiration
to someone hundreds and hundreds of
years down the
line well you know uh
similarly uh geosynchronous orbit are
you guys familiar with the idea of
geosynchronous orbit yeah sat like stays
above the same point right you know so
the the planet's here and we launch a
satellite that's so high up that as it
rotates it it remain it stays right on
top of the of a spot on earth that's
most of your communication satellite or
that because you don't want them in the
in the past they were all geosynchronous
now we've got constellations of
satellites are even better but Arthur C
Clark the science fiction writer came up
with that idea in the
40s 1945 I believe at wire at wire world
or something some sort of uh Wireless
World in 1945 in that issue and he came
up with this idea and he's a and he's a
science fiction writer you know so the
you know the Science Guy the military
guy probably H I wonder if that would
work you know
and that that is all on him a Sci-Fi
writer came up with that and it it it
was the backbone of um it still is the
backbone of all of our um Communications
on planet Earth these days yeah um I
said there that you know he basically
forsaw satellites iPads the internet um
exploring the solar system even though
you could argue that that was been
written before him but
um at what point did you have start
thinking wondering whether AR Arthur C
Clark was a piging time traveler the man
had really forsaw 50 years ahead of his
life yeah he was writing it um and
nobody had really thought about putting
seriously thought about putting objects
in space like that and before him even
though we obviously we had seen um um I
can't remember the name of the book now
but um Jules Vern wrote about going to
the Moon didn't he and things like this
in in in rocket ships and things but
yeah but a giant firework basically is
the way he saw it but and obviously You'
got that old Chinese proverb about the
guy that put put a loot of fireworks
onto his chair because he wanted to get
into space or wanted to get to the moon
and blew up don't think is that a real
story was that just a madeup story I
forget I forget I can't remember if it's
a proverb or not but anyway um but we've
always looked up the we and try to go
that bit
further men will always dream men men
will always come up with not not just
men I'm not I'm not I'm not saying men
no only
menes men will always dream and F will
always imagine and come up with ideas
and then other men will come along or
women I'm inclusive will come along will
come along and make those dreams a
reality that's always going to happen MH
and I think that's amazing I could come
up with an idea right now I could say
something and in a 100 years time not
that anyone's going to watch Sid Trek in
100 years time but someone might and
then they'll go oh Matt made that made
that lovely point I'm gonna make that a
reality like the idea that that could
happen is I love it the idea of thinking
that something can happen though is very
different to then actually obviously
making it happen is because anybody can
come up with that billion dollar idea
and say okay that's a great idea that's
fantastic let yes people would like to
be able to um eat pizza and not gain
weight how are we going to do it and
that that's
the a lot of a lot of discoveries like
that happen by
accident like a lot of things a lot of
Technology emerges because they they're
working on something and then something
else happens and they go oh maybe we can
use that for something else or they're
studying something and they study the
effects of what that thing is doing and
then
that recreate and then the new
technology is born I don't think
necessarily they always set out I mean
sometimes they do I mean people are
trying to cure cancer right now that's
that's that's a good example of setting
out to achieve a goal but a lot of
discoveries in the past W I'm going to
set out to invent the light bulb that
Tomy said I don't think he's set out to
do that he was doing experiments and
then accidentally maybe not accidentally
because he had a method of what he was
doing but he invented the light bulb
through his
for his methodology where that might
there was a race to
invent um Thom was a bad idea because it
was Nicola Tesla that created it in the
first place but oh there's about 20
different people that between
them yeah apparently and you could argue
that Edison just went to the patent
office and went that that and that
patent that for me thank you very much
um and danced off to the
presidency
but that's a different argument um but
this is one for you stormmy I'm thinking
has sci-fi led us to being um to be
disappointed by the actual reality
because obviously our stormmy build
spaceships for a living um which is you
know very
cool and not once has he invited us not
once all I want to do is go to space Man
by the way Harris can you just like wave
or something every so often so I
remember you're there so I remember to
ask you to do I look alive you look
looks better than a screen so I remember
to introduce
but a big conspiracy theory at the
moment right is that um we've already
been to the moon and things and we've
already we're already mining it and
there's a load of I I'm GNA use because
I actually work in mental health a
little bit so I'm going to use the
technical term now Nutters believe that
we're we're already on Mars we're
already in thing we're using alien
technology and all this sort thing right
um
then we um right when I'm taking a sip
Nutters so um so we're then gonna do
things like the Orion Project and we're
going to put um an orbitting base around
the moon in the next few years we're
going to return to the moon and
hopefully then go to Mars but the
technology basically is exactly the same
it's refined it's better don't get me
wrong the metals are better blah blah
blah but it's still you know big fun
go up sort thing but in science fiction
has science fiction sort of made us all
think that actually more is possible
than actually is some sense uh maybe
more possible we could think of now
19 what was it was it
19 60 something or
another Arthur C Clark you know wrote
2001 A Space Odyssey I can't remember
what years that was
uh anyway a lot of the things in space
out and then of course the film was made
after that
um but it was the uh 60s when that I
think it was the 60s when that came out
um there were a lot of
things in
that we're still discussing today I mean
you know the ethics of
AI of 19 uh let's see um still trying to
find the the date the book came out not
the
movie um but right now we're discussing
I mean every day on the news there's the
ethics of AI will AI take
over know and
um I hope so oh yeah so it was uh 1951
The Sentinel was the name of the
original story
and then cubber got the rights and made
you know called it 2001 Space Odyssey
but yeah it was from The Sentinel and
that was
1951 fellas 1951 is when that
was and here almost 75 years later now
we have chat
gbt you know now we are really
discussing the app the moral
applications of AI and here we you know
in The Sentinel we had you know AI on a
spaceship on a murder spree y 70
something years ago yeah yeah yeah yeah
and
um so I
think there are two there there are
Visionaries right there's your
Visionaries and then there were sci-fi
writers that were good Visionaries
because just because you're Visionary
doesn't mean you can write [__] you know
you're not you not very good you don't
have a grasp but storytelling but some
of these guys um
were on it you know
um like for our our health care disaster
at least here in
America uh was really kind of U
Illustrated in the
book Gateway by Frederick
pole and that was I don't know how many
years
ago Jay's muted himself I stopped
listening for a second because I was
eating a crisp where we how was the
crisp it was lovely was spicy actually
oh spicy taco I got I got I got Hot
Doritos but I got a very very hot one
all the all the chili was on one damn
crisp the rest would be
rubbish by the way because the sun's
come out and I had two beers in the
fridge i' forgotten about I was like
beer so yeah 1977 is when Frederick pole
wrote Gateway and it's about us finding
um
uh abandoned spaceships in a polar orbit
of the Sun but in the um the two main
things I loved about the book that I
think are what was
predicting you know the American
disaster known as Healthcare was how it
was represented in a book everybody was
poor and really you know your whole life
was dedicated to get Blue Cross you know
that you had to get that insurance plan
but if you're really [__] Rich you
get Blue Cross plus so if you lose an
arm you find some poor person you pay
them however much money you take their
arm put it on
you you know and uh as the book as the
trilogies go for on you know the the
healthare plan how far off do you think
particularly if Trump becomes president
how far off do you think um is that for
America 10 years you used the t- word
again the Brits said it now I gotta go
some [__] about
Mar any Republican gets in how far off
do you think America is off that well
have you seen Mitch McConnell
lately that man needs a whole new thing
I always think he looks like a
heum he looks like a turtle look you
look at him very closely it's a turtle
like an ctis you know so so um I saw
this meme this morning and it was just
genius was um the there was the guy
sitting at a table outside you know
sipping coffee and says something
something changed my mind well here was
that guy with the head of Mitch
McConnell and it was just blank changed
my
mind just I'm not horrible he's a very
old
man but have you seen have you seen that
movie um this a sci-fi movie it's
actually a good one sorry just in Tim
blank and it something in time I think
it was called yeah he yeah had that
golum lady in it yeah yeah yeah big eyes
very pretty um looks like go um and that
was basically that everybody lived
forever because of a new drug so time
was the only thing that really like
mattered so you just you so you you were
paid in time and then he he finds
somebody that's got like a 100,000 years
on his because he's wealthy That's the
basis of wealth as if you how much time
you've got and I just thought that was
such a clever thing because we're
actually moving towards being medication
in a future now that will basically
eliminate old
age because the body wants to re the
body wants to repair itself it stops
doing that at a certain point and we
start to age but in theory there's
nothing to say that we can't turn that
genetic marker off and I did see
something about ago basically saying
this one research team thinks they're
about five years away from being able to
do it the world becomes a very different
place all of a sudden if we stop
aging are you referring to Brian
Johnson's team have you heard of Brian
Johnson he's a billionaire I believe uh
that is dedicated to keeping himself
deaged at the moment he is I think like
48 or 50 and has like the metabolic
structure of a 22y old something like
that he announces this stuff all the
time oh this does all these really weird
like he does like fasting and he does
all these different like things to lower
his metabolic um age a lot of things
like that also medications and stuff
yeah he's he takes like 130 supplements
a day or something wild like that that
might even be like a low number for him
uh but it's insane him his son who's a
little younger than me I believe and
then his dad are all doing the same
thing and his dad's like 70s or 80s and
I think he's supposed to have the
metabolic structure of like a 40y old or
something like that I don't know believe
that his very important to have very
good health and that your body is a
temple and you should be really careful
what you put into it because um you know
you you get ill else you know it's like
I'm gonna live forever is that gay
Budweiser no it's just Budweiser just I
was gonna get Bud Light just to annoy
people but I thought better not
um I I'd forgotten I had them it's great
I the f one oh my God where they come
from forgot I had them um put them
[Laughter]
I I have a can of Fosters in my fridge
that I left I left a job when I worked
at Tesco like a year and a half ago they
gave me a crate of Fosters and I've been
slowly giving away to my father-in-law
every time he comes around I've got one
can left I hate
it I feel the same way about Bud do
about fizzy we Fosters so in terms of of
of d structure and changing your DNA and
metabolic rates and so forth there's
another sci-fi novel that uh um that
touched on it it's a little bit more
modern novel and by modern I mean you
know
1992 it's uh the uh it's called Uh red
Mars by Kim Stanley Robinson and in that
they have there's um they Humanity goes
to Mars starts a colony there's
conflict um but one of the scientists
you know um
he's been you know working on this
problem you know the longevity I mean
you you're not Immortal because you can
still get killed by hitting getting in
front of a you know traveling bus but he
talks about these rats he's been uh
working on and uh this guy comes and say
well how old are they says well these
rats here are 15 years old you know and
then it becomes this um on Earth this
technology transferred from Mars to
Earth and then everybody becomes a human
right then everybody gets a shot it's
called the shot not the jab which was a
CO thing but anyway they get the shot
and and in it they talk about people are
so desperate for this is the cers that
they administer the shot people will go
and camp out for weeks just so they
won't miss their place in
line and um thank you K it it and one
thing about like about Kim Stanley
Robinson is
uh his uh ability
to make the scientists the heroes you
know and there's other things that came
along with uh this uh
treatment U that mitigated uh
overpopulation you know like restricting
uh child birth etc etc that you had to
agree to if you did get the the shot but
um I genuinely believe that we should
just stick with our generation and um
not bother with anymore
we you just get a medication that makes
us stop aging and in in stormy's case
reverses it significantly let's do that
retrograde [__] yeah
yeah Harris has got a few years yet of
growing he can he can still grow up a
little bit yeah um but then just don't
bother with anymore the kids just needs
anahist toine I think yeah I'm just like
my kids really should be take on my
laptop bloody modern
technology as good as it's going to get
guys let's let's not bother um I just
think that the world if we all stopped
aging man the world would
be
ridiculously well I can't even imagine
it it's one of those things you know you
see um s Quest thank you very much
coming a new member thank you very much
sir um the whole I think amortality
makes us it's I just think it's
important because you know you right
when you're a teenager you have no
definition of mortality right you think
you're going to live forever you think
you're absolutely invincible and that's
you know going to go on and that's why I
think most teenagers are complete Pricks
and then you know you start to get a bit
older and you start to realize that
there is a mortality and you grow up and
you calm down a little bit and you start
being a bit more careful and you start
paying into a pension pot which just
makes me want to cry but you you have to
you know these things but if I was still
there generally
believed if I couldn't if I didn't age I
just think the the our culture and
everything would just stagnate
and would be it would be horrific it
just be a bunch of teenagers running
around we'd all they'd be World War 3i
and we'd all be dead but within a week
if that happened
yeah um but it's so when you talk when
we talk about science um and generally
what's possible in the universe so like
like for example like flying cars or the
hoverboard in you know the future too
and things like this you know that those
and people I I genuinely think sometimes
people genuinely think these things are
possible and that when we then talk
about going back to the Moon people go
well that's easy and I do think maybe
science fiction has an influence on that
because we watch these things on TV and
we watch these things on and so when
then we think the engineering of that is
doable even though our computers today
are way more powerful than anything we
ever saw on Star Trek um it just seems
there seems to be that in they maybe the
non not so educated there's this
attitude of well that's easy why don't
we why don't we just why is it so hard
well it it's not to be Devil's Advocate
or anything but it isn't that hard I
mean space is hard let me let me just
you know because it's it's a pain in a
dick for engineering that said we did it
50 years ago and it's not that we can't
do these things it's we don't want to
pay for them mmhm I mean we could have I
mean you know we we stopped going to the
moon at Apollo
17 we had already had the hardware built
for 1819 and 20 it was the the Apollo
program was supposed to be a 20 Mission
program and we already had the hardware
built if you want to see what the
remnants of it just go to you know a and
Space Museums around the world yeah
there's the big titan there's the lunar
lander and all this shit's in museums
now because we had it built didn't use
it Richard millhous [__]
Nixon um cancelled it cancelled the moon
program so we get a gone back 20 time
you know 20 more times if we'd gone
rolled that over there are already plans
for the the um the next generation of
Rocket you know the Saturn
6 and there was already plans I mean
these this was an engineered vehicle
already and um there was plans is yeah
the next step I mean back in those days
you know I mean it was on the news the
next step is Mars we had already decided
we were going to go to Mars before
Apollo 17 we'd already committed
ourselves intellectually and emotionally
that oh yeah America is going to Mars
next because [__] yeah space but we
didn't because there wasn't the
political
will what an element though that there's
also the realization that why are we
going other than the you know expansion
of knowledge and exploration I think in
the 60s was there a and then we gone
back to money again was there a
financial reason to
go to the Moon Mars
Beyond was there a financial reason to
go well today I say today we do because
we want to mine the crap out of it I
would say minerals we the the the
Financial uh realities of space travel
and going to
space
um that was discussed all the time and
uh we always saw it as a profitable uh
profitable Endeavor because the things
you get out of it I mean all the things
we're we're talking about mostly today
the technology existed because of the
absolute [__] ton of money we spent on
the uh Space Program
all of those soon trickled out spun off
into technologies that we use
today and that built and we built on top
of that and if you do the critical
analysis of it NASA is the only
Department United States government that
actually makes money that doesn't get to
keep the money that goes into the
treasury and then Congress wastes it on
fossil fuels or some [__] um but
yeah there's always been the the
financial use case you know uh and
especially um in terms of land to settle
or or spa place U surface area planetary
surface area to settle and but yeah the
the use case for the financial part was
always right there but Nixon was
Nixon I don't know what's going on in J
there's some sort of slurping chewing or
going on oh
you made me think while you were saying
all that there I don't know if there was
necessarily a financial reasoning for
them to do things besides obviously the
beginning of the Cold War we we have
this kind of Space Race and there are
all these things going on these things
are just being spoken in the public all
across the globe and we're kind of
putting things out there that we have to
follow up on after the fact the Cold War
still goes on for 25 30 years after we
get to space yeah we don't necessarily
go we go back to space frequently but we
don't go to to space and land on the
moon attempt to go to Mars we're not
even trying to go to Venus or anything
like that they uh we're not trying to
like establish more bases on the moon
it's more like okay we got our
International Space Station why would
they have never found on the moon they
found aliens on the moon the aliens told
him never to come back and then they
made a documentary and it was that was
what became the Transformers movie ah I
thought it was going to be moonfall for
a second um no no Transformers movie I
love
Elon well uh uh it's been 30 40 years
since we've actually been on the moon
right and then India just went to the
just landed a robot on the moon this
last week yeah yeah we have landed stuff
on the moon before but yeah it's been a
while since we've since a human I guess
set foot well that was 60 yeah 70
something so 50
years but um but the reason is now that
obviously we have these we have this
need there's we go in our batteries we
really really need batteries we're going
to run out of it we have to go and get
it somewhere else there are metals that
we desperately need we're going to have
to go out and get it we're going to have
to mine the meteor belts and the Mars
and the moon and everything else and get
all this there's crack load of titanium
on the moon for example loads of it um
and it's quite reasonably easy to get to
so I I'm not sure the the technology
existed to actually mine anything back
in the 60s and 70s that technology is
get better now we could I think there's
a financial reason
now exactly space suit axe Spade done
well I mean we did mining on the moon
that's exactly how they chipped off
these Rock samples they had mining
tools a couple weeks ago I was at the
New Mexico Museum of space history and
they had one of those um shock resistant
uh mining picks on
display it's awesome am um popcorn PL
said the metals will always be easy to
mine on here that's the problem is that
there some of the metals we're talking
about are quite exotic and they just
don't exist here it's not to get them is
that they they they reckon is it what's
it in
batteries lithium lithium we've got
about 100 years worth at today's rate of
use we've got run out silicone as well
and
that's oh my God my head's exploding
we're not running out of silic
uh the Earth's crust is 25% silicat if
we run out of that we're we're living in
lava Fields I mean we're not running out
of we we're running out of sand that we
can use in concrete is that what we were
talking about we're not
running just Gul of Mexico can provide
enough sand for concrete for the next
thousand years I don't
know because the sand isn't the right
sort of I sorry I read up on this a
little while ago the Sand's the wrong
shape right so the sand land in the
Sahara Desert they've only very recently
figured out how to use it to make
concrete because it's sharp and spiky so
you can't use it for concrete but very
recently somebody figured out how so the
whole thing with sand running out they
think is solved but it's quite hard they
have to use loads of quite evasive
chemicals and things on it you know and
now there's technology to to recycle
concrete back into its constituent
anyway uh going back to the uh thing
about mining on Earth is cheaper that's
not true true um there's a a mission
that NASA is planning to us what's
called an an asteroid called psych 16
it's uh probably one of the bigger
um uh asteroids in the in the asteroid
belt it's mostly precious metals but if
you take the average metallic asteroid
in the asteroid
belt and you go and and and mine it and
keep in mind that this is almost all
pure metal there's no basalt rock
there's no Organics like you find here
in um or on Earth one of those one of
those average size largest asteroid you
find in the asteroid B one of
those is equal to about the same amount
of metal you would find if you strip
mined North
America now which is more costly go out
put a robot on the Rock in the asteroid
belt between here and Mars putt it to
over to Earth orbit or mine it there
mine it on Mars then the strip mine the
entirety of North America that's no one
lives there as well you can no one lives
there there no environmental concerns if
you want to go and set off a couple of
nukes on an asteroid somewhere to free
up a bunch you know I mean you could you
could Blast Away quite happily and
nobody from Green Piece is going to turn
up if they do you're going to tip you
out to and go fair play you got you got
a spaceship and drag yourself all the
way over here complain about AR so you
mean it's it's that's the future um what
about all the tiny little microbial
species that live on the asteroid Pro
don't start don't go don't get them
started mate the
futuris because most Plastics are based
on on hydrocarbons
so and there's also plenty of
hydrocarbons in space we can go get
hydrocarbons in space we can make
hydrocarbons if we really really need to
it's more expensive than just sucking it
out have any more if I eat beans today I
will make plenty of
hydrocarbons um the the world was
predicted to run out of oil people keep
saying that we're going to run out of
oil and then another there's there's a
myth that went round last year that said
we're not going to run out of oil
because the earth makes more and it's
not true um but we will not run out of
oil what we will do though is it will
become so expensive to get to the oil
that is left it becomes just
ridiculously expensive
but we
have Technology's improved so about 20
30 years ago they said we had 50 years
left um because they found a few more
oil reserves and the Technologies
improved they think we've still got
about 50 years left before it starts
getting complicated of
proven reserves that we can actually get
to and then some somebody might think of
a new way of sucking it up cheaply and
you know we might might go a bit further
but it's the
cost in the end of day we've got the
easy stuff we're now starting to suck
out the hard stuff and it gets more
difficult it gets more complicated
simple as that one second sorry so what
we need is a massive straw and everyone
just get on one end and we just suck as
hard as we
can everyone and if if one person
doesn't suck hard then we fail so we've
all got to suck as hard as we
can um yeah I know and then we'd all be
fine wouldn't we what we basically need
is to so harder damn it um but to go
about that then is is there is there
really a point that that is is sci-fi
related to why people think that we're
able to do more than is actually
realistic that that you know because we
see all these amaz things in science
because you see things you see things in
science fiction like I mean this
probably would happen in real life but I
think this is why it's in people's head
if an asteroid was heading towards and
their only hope is to build a rocket and
send it up to deflect the asteroid they
in the movies they do it like within the
space of a week or two weeks or whatever
right and yes if that was happening in
real life they probably would have a
rocket they could
do but I think that's why people think
it's so easy because like well you can
do it if you really really really want
it to but those are special
circumstances like dire circumstance
like Resort we we pull all the resources
together and we just make it happen find
circum th everything into I think we're
capable of doing like science fiction
level stuff is it that there is either
there's no need to or it costs too much
but actually yeah if there was a
meteorite about to hit the planet and we
had to I think we're capable of shitload
of stuff stormy one thing I
think genuinely interested in this thing
you know the stuff that we're capable of
do particularly in space travel I've
always wondered if one thing that's
holding us back is um a power source and
that if we had a
better way of dragging energy with us
that we would actually be capable of
doing like near sci-fi things the reason
why we still use Rockets So is because
we don't have a way of generating enough
energy
safely didn't someone actually design a
Walk Drive like the design what how it
would work the only thing stopping them
was the power source
taking that much mass and putting it
down to the size of a pin prick but yeah
yeah what we're you know what you're
talking about is reaction versus re
reactionless uh engines everything that
runs in space is reaction it you provide
a some sort of a force you know let's
say you have a rocket and you want to
move the rocket one way or another you
have to have a blast of some sort of
matter changing the deflection as you're
travel uh
so and the blast you just got to have
that reaction force you know for every
action there's an equal and opposite
reaction but what we're looking for what
we and and there's been a lot of
progress in this area is a
reactionless uh space motor space engine
and ironically I think the the biggest
advances in that's come from CERN the
large hron collider better understand of
how quarks work you know if you look on
an and an atomic scale the universe is
mostly in empty you know you on in a
square um meter you may have or cubic
meter of um of just vacuum space you may
have one single atom of hydrogen it's
very very
empty but at the quantum level it's
densely packed with [__] I mean that
that and that's one thing that we really
have discovered
recent in terms human terms recently is
how densely packed space is with Quantum
matter and so now if we can figure out a
way how to push against the quantum
matter that's there then we can come up
with reactionless engines and skidadle
as about as fast as we want because
until we figure that out we're we're
stuck with propulsion nonetheless right
yeah we're stuck with the chemical
propulsion even if we were able to get
like a nuclear reactor small enough to
put into like a ship or something like
that it would still have to be propulsed
or propulsion to to a degree right yes
uh answering sci-fi Quest is question
yes it's um powerful enough to propel a
craft we've already got sat ion have ion
drive some yeah the the first one there
was this the first experiment NASA did
was a space probe called Deep Space one
named after our favorite Star Trek
series and what it does it it um
it kind of strips away the electrons
from an
atom and thrusts it out now the thing
about ion
engines is that it's very slow
acceleration yeah but it lasts a long
time so the force of an ion Thruster is
about the same Force as a piece of paper
resting on your hand that's it's not
very much force at all but it doesn't
turn off and so it goes and goes and
goes whereas a regular chemical uh
rocket like SpaceX or or lock heat or
whoever it will I mean it'll just turn
on and it'll just blast just go and go
for about 90 seconds or maybe two or
three minutes you got minutes worth but
with ion thrusters you have years and
sometimes decades worth it just needs a
little you're you're just you know if
you got something with a lot of atoms on
it and I think usually they're propelled
by Xenon atoms a lot of there's lots of
um electrons on a Xenon atom so you're
getting the most out of the fuel but it
goes and goes and goes and goes for a
very long time so yeah um there was I
think now we have several spacecraft
that uses ion uh engines but it's a very
limited kind of thing but you want it
for long-term missions it's not very
good for shortterm
stuff we we started looking at there's
um an idea to go to Alpha centu and
that's going to use an ion drive and but
the idea being basically we're gonna
send I saw a debate between these nties
said it's gonna take about 50 years to
get there and the other guy saying well
but how do you know that we won't come
up with something that we'd end up Le
frogging it so we could we could end up
spending a lot of time and effort to
send this satellite that's going to take
50 years to get to this St and
actually how do we know in 20 years time
we won't do something they could get
there in five years and Beat It by 208
you know what I mean it's like so they
they're trying to debate on whether it
was even worth doing or not with Co
technology or should we wait until the
next and then they went on about all
these different Technologies they
thought could leap Frogg it obviously
but um that will always be the case
though let's just send a bunch of mother
ships and Seed a bunch of planets with
um solar solar um sails and ion
thrusters let's do it use less energy
and just go for it well that's one of
the theories behind it why they might be
aliens because um is it the oh I forget
the
Paradox the guy that came up with it the
Paradox he said I mean if it's if a
society lasted long enough um even with
today's modern technology yeah we could
we could seed every planet in this in
the solar system given long enough and
they we haven't seen that so that means
there aren't any aliens but well going
back to the the 50 year issue uh you
know in
1977 we launched the Voyager
probes you know and they're still going
and they've exited the solar system and
that was 50 years ago you know so if we
can build a probe or a satellite or
something that can get to another star
system in 50 years I mean that's well
within our mission lifetime these days
you know if you look at the probes on
Mars are supposed to last like you know
three months and they go for decades
because there it it's we're just getting
really good at that uh but yeah if it's
a 50-year mission and let's say we do
come up with something in 20 years you
know we could use that technology to
Leap Frog to the next star system you
know it doesn't necessarily we have to
go to the same place well we've already
got something you know and it'll it'll
arrive in 30 years well let's go use
this new technology does it in half the
time to go someplace else to Leap Frog
to explore farther you know so I know in
terms of um space exploration if we had
technology to send a probe to uh the
next star system over in only 50 years I
think it's doable because we've got two
probes now that just left a solar system
a few years ago and they're about
they're 50 years
old the lifetime of it is not the real
the problem they were arguing whether
whether it's use worth doing but I would
argue that if you if you always wait for
the next technology you'll never do
anything
exactly um just very yeah it's like you
know do I get the new iPhone now or I
wait till you know mons from you know
never get the next one would you
tomorrow never comes yeah yeah yeah yeah
so just quickly c.co don't forget that
that's our new um committed website that
um it is we put stories on there about
all of our videos so please go check
that out also please check out for the
description for links to Matthews nerd
in the corner um YouTube channel
Harris's channel that we're desperately
trying to get name because he does
videos way better than we do on this
channel and our stormy bear who has his
very educational Channel and if you want
to learn how to make hydrogen and blow
[__] up yeah actually the FBI might turn
up if we talkop about that too
much make hydrogen but not blow anything
up but not blow anything up to
responsibly use it as an alternative
power source in your exactly there are
links to that all of the different
channels in the description and they're
also on our Affiliated channels thing
aren't they mat you can scroll down to
on the bottom of the page and they're
down there somewhere aren they indeed
please go over and check all those out
while we're on right so we got one more
oh we got two more little things to add
to the bottom that I wanted to just to
talk about so
um how much art Engineers genuinely
influenced by science fiction then if we
talked about the mobile phone we've
talked about iPads we've talked about
satellites and all these things that
were imagined by science fiction but is
there actually a reality where Engineers
today are influenced by science fiction
and if so by how much nowadays a th%
totally and it it it's as simple as just
saying 3D printers honestly because
that's going to be the future of of all
engineering at some point whether it be
bioengineering actual engineering we're
we're learning to print food we're
learning to print organs were already
printing print houses yeah I actually I
went to I grew up going to church with a
dude that uh lives in Austin that is
printing houses and got uh contract with
NASA or whatever to do that um but it's
it's 3D printings the future and if it's
that accessible to anybody as long as
you know what what coding to put in
there and and get the thing you want out
of
it the only thing stopping you his
imagination kind of cool here here's the
this is an alternative Theory um we
are uh three inventions away from the
total collapse of
capitalismo so there's three thing you
know if you once there there's three
legs of the stool that's that's a
propping up capitalism one is uh energy
you know once you know we are striving
to get you know make energy free or nil
cost once you get to because every
everything you buy today has energy the
cost of energy built in fossil fuels
Renewables whatever it is always built
in that cost if you can get energy to
zero or nil cost that collapses many
many Industries but it also democratizes
a lot of things that you'll need for the
next thing which would be uh
production and production is just what
you know Harris just said was 3D
printing you know once you can get to
the point of 3D printing objects you
know you become one step step closer to
having the replicators in Star Trek you
know where you know if you want food you
just order food if you want just makes
mean the good replicators in Star Trek
not the bad replicators in Stargate we
just want to just to clarify that point
two very different things so if you
wanted you know self steming
self-sealing stem bolts you can have all
you want there you go
and you know and so uh then there's of
course to put something into 3D printer
it's not just a matter of turn on and
just magic to say there's an inherent
flaw there yeah yeah I don't think we'll
ever get rid of capitalism capitalism is
is just part of the human existence and
I I think it's kind of naive to just be
like no capitalism all the time and I
know we love to do that as a society but
literally everything has a market and
think capitalism is necessarily a human
capitalism started forever because yeah
capitalism hasn't been around that long
163 when capitalism started 16 when
Caven were trading sticks that's
different you have Commerce and
capitalism socialism and communism
that's just Commerce Commerce is
different from your economic
model I mean you know face it I mean
Indians the Native Americans they had
Commerce it's a different thing than
capitalism if there's ambition
capitalism is there and humans never
don't have ambition well capitalism is a
whole different capitalism capitalism
started with the uh Dutch East Indie uh
East India Company you know with the its
model shareh holders it's it was a
totally different animal and you know
and of course what Thomas Jefferson
called The
Commonwealth well Commonwealth was a
much earlier word than socialism
socialism is a rather more modern world
word that came after Thomas
Jefferson and but yeah capitalism is
easily uh done away with because it's
only hasn't been around for just a few
hundred years anyway going back to the
thing so you have you know energy and
you have production and then you have
um you know housing you things like that
but the the thing that it will be the
most difficult to do because there's a
finite resource of this on Earth and
that's called ariable land you have to
have land capitalism requires land to
build land to rent land to live on land
to produce things but once you start
interject you throw in Star Travel into
it and you can start colonizing other
land you know once you start doing that
all of a sudden the resource of land
becomes infinite instead of finite and
you know there's nothing that can uh
withstand that in terms of
capitalism I you're in well in with in a
post scarcity economy and scarcity is
what drives capitalism I would agree
with Harris that there's I think there
is an element of psychology to
capitalism
that we like we like like we said if we
want to you want to but you've always
got we talk about this the other week
and I'm sorry I'm going to start again
but in group out group thinking and how
we want to feel um there's this thing
been um about people's um self-identity
and when they were working class in the
mines that they would um they did
surveys on them and they recorded being
quite happy and then the minds closed
and they went into other cleaner work
force forces and all of a sudden we had
a real problem in the UK particularly of
like um mental health issues with men
and the the issue they they after very
several studies they found out that it
was because a lot of these men and women
that used to consider themselves working
class didn't know who they were anymore
y so they didn't because it was based on
that I I'm A working class and that's
okay because I know who the med the
middle class person is and I know who
the upper class person is and as long as
I know what that hierarchy is then I'm
quite comfortable we now have a world
where everybody's middle class and
there's a little bit of upper class and
basically everyone else is middle class
and there's a little bit of working you
know like people on the door but mostly
we've got this massive middle class SE
nobody knows who they are compared to
each other capitalism is one way that
allows us to do that and it feeds into
that psychology so I've got the new car
the neighbors only got the the 2003
model um and it it feeds into that basic
psychology that we all have and that's
why we quite like it as a as a as people
yeah and you take that away that's why
communism doesn't work in its purest
form and when they did Communism they
threw in they had to throw in a punch of
a pinch of Commerce but capitalism
really because there was still that
still that hierarchy it's basic human
psychology um but I agree with you stor
me and that that if you get resources
become so plentiful and energy becomes
virtually
free capitalism I think would still be
there but it would be so watered down
and so really unimportant that it would
be virtually non-existent then once you
take manufacturing out of it you know
then it becomes even more unstable you
know you keep going down the road until
you're left with the only thing you're
left with to buy and sell as a commodity
is land because there's only so much of
it you can do anything with on earth
once you start star travel all of a
sudden land becomes infinite available
land becomes infinite and you could
argue because we've already made money
virtual it doesn't really exist then um
we'll R you offway there anyway and the
psychology you're talking about was uh
also existed before 16002 uh exist in
just not just capitalism but socialism
and communism so it's kind of
independent I mean the psychology is
independent of the monetary policy you
have
um and you know I guess if you ask the
Native Americans C ISM really hasn't
worked for them you know and the ter in
in terms of like middle class I think
it's more of a uh I mean these days it's
more of a um first world uh feature that
does not include the United
States I quies we like hierarchy we like
to know where we are in the world and
that's I think most successful cultures
through history they've had some sort
sort of system to monage that we now do
it through
capitalism we
we capitalism and that's why we're all
such bloody um well Amazon does so well
because we're all so desperate to have
the next new thing um it all stems from
that basic psychology but you know
you're familiar with maso's hierarchy of
human needs the pyramid yeah and once
you what you know those three things
that I just mentioned the three were
three inventions away from the collaps
capitalism those are the first two
layers of maso's pyramid everything else
is kind of your happiness is kind of up
to you you know but once you take care
of food security housing security all
that you know and
education well you
know everything you build everything
else off that yeah then you build emo
needs rather than physical needs but
yeah so I actually did read a couple of
papers I think you mentioned it earlier
stormy about um how much Engineers are
actually influenced by science fiction
and MIT have done loads of studies on
this and they've said basically every
year when they look at it how many news
when somebody an engineer reports
releases a new report on something how
many times science fiction or science
fiction elements are actually mentioned
yeah and increasing steadily that over
now nearly half of the papers that
released worldwide every year are
mentioned something to do with science
fiction so we can argue that Engineers
are genuinely influenced by the science
fiction of the world so we so that goes
into the next thing I was going to say
was science fiction has molded the world
that we live in well let me let me
finish up the previous thought where I
was going with all this but the three
inventions of the destroy capitalism was
I know people in Silicon Valley that's
working on all three of those problems
you know replicator
technology um in you know in not
infinite well yeah kind of cheap and nil
cost energy cheaper nil cost
Manufacturing you know and space travel
um and it my my opinion is if Congress
had the slightest idea what is going
down in Silicon Valley they would nuke
the site for morbid I mean because it is
the destructive [__] huh that would be
illegal that'd be well Congress can make
anything space bace weapon
systems well but but seriously I mean I
know guys in Silicon valet it's working
on all three of these problems and and
um Congress doesn't have an idea what's
going on not the slightest clue they I
mean half of Congress still doesn't
believe there're such such saying is
climate change which
is not manmade that'd be
silly Matt wake up a sec Matt oh my God
we lost Matt Mt are you alive Earth the
Matt science fiction then has molded
world world that we live in no we I
would fall asleep during stormy's rant
just like you fell asleep during my rant
on Wednesday so you got Bo towards the
end um but I mean the modern world that
we live in though how much of it is
molded by sort of not in science fiction
but our culture
art all these stuff of things is there a
is there
a is there you know a connection between
the
two I think science fiction often gives
us the idea of the perfect world
and
through wanting a perfect world maybe we
subconsciously try and adapt not not
adopt some of those ideas and
ideologies that could come into it bit
bit of um
psychology involved in that some way but
yeah I think I think I think because
science fiction
does give us essentially the perfect
world I think it's only natural that it
influences more than just technology but
some of the ideals that some of us have
I mean I mean the ideals that I
have um I would be considered a
liberal I guess um but I attribute that
to a lot of Science Fiction not a live
Dam not a live Dam just I'm a liberal
thinker like I open-minded human right
open-minded human rights um
if there's a if there's a debate to be
have I'm on the I'm on the side of
the the one that's being oppressed
essentially that's generally where I sit
on the political political
scale um but I attribute I see a lot of
that in science fiction and I can't help
but think that maybe science fiction
influenced that in
me I agree Harris science fiction then
generally can tends to get split into
two halves it tends to be a positive
Star Trek future or a dystopian
postapocalyptic negative future do you
think actually both sides can influence
in the in in a similar way that it's not
just our hopes but our fees oh totally I
mean that every time we bring up AI I'm
always saying like give us C3PO not
Skynet you know like yeah yeah there's
different there's different options that
and avenues that we can take and we as a
people uh as a species can choose to
take I guess those those different
options
and I'd rather Choose The Optimist kind
of version most of the time uh we we
tend to fearmonger and scare ourselves
into choosing the safest thing that can
always just be turned off or or switched
up I guess by like a little switch or
something I don't know uh but I I'd much
prefer a a C3PO than a Skynet and I
think that can apply to a everything
almost yeah te isn't negative or
positive it depends on how you use it
whether it's evil or technology is
yeah Stormy then I mean when we're
talking about how much scii has
influenced us is it really because I
think is this is it a chicken and egg
type of thing is it because sci-fi's
influenced us or because of our hopes
and fears influence ccii because it's an
art form at the end of the day
well not a lot of people have looked at
the Mona Lisa and decided to go invent
something even though that the art form
of painting and Mona Lisa is kind of up
there on the ranks of a of
well-respected
art it maybe Inspire some sort of
emotion but it doesn't really
Inspire um moving Humanity forward in
terms of
Technology uh so so there are you know
science fiction is an art form that has
in its ability to
um to move Humanity forward you know
whether it's through invention or
ideas or something but pushing Humanity
forward seems to be the thing that we
get as a side effect in humans when we
read science
fiction
um and I think that's different from
like fantasy books which
um shows what humans can or can do uh in
terms of heroics and empathy and really
good potato soup recipes you know what I
mean second breakfast yeah yeah yeah
second breakfast but so I do I think
you're right I mean you know it's I
think
sci-fi and and you know I'm not just
using sci-fi in books you know sci-fi in
books and film in just singular pieces P
of art I think um Can Inspire us or it
can uh law it can uh dislodge our
curiosity in a way that is really mind
openening I
remember uh seeing the first Star Wars
poster at the local theater and I
marveled at it I mean it was just oh my
God and it was just a single picture you
know wasn't this is not just a movie my
mind was really blown when I saw the
film
but you know it really
does what you know it really does
trigger us what's possible where can we
go what we can achieve we know when we
work together and what we can destroy
when we
don't I think a lot of modern sci-fi
though I think I think there's a lot of
negativity in sci-fi and and in a lot of
media at the moment to be honest there's
there's a lot of Doom and
Gloom I mean Matt you watch as much TV
as I do and read is there is there a
darker future ahead of the moment I mean
because if science fiction does tend to
reflect where we're going and it has
done a lot in the
past does that mean we should be maybe
more worried about the future
than in the
[Music]
past I don't
know I don't necessarily think when we
see Doom and Gloom it's a reflection of
what's actually happening in the world I
think it's the opposite when it's when
things are happy in the world or at
least not dire we see more Doom and
Gloom when things are a little bit more
Doom and Gloom we see things that are
more
happy
so I don't know may maybe we are in for
some more Doom and Gloom who knows but
then we'll get some more Happy Sci-Fi so
so swings and roundabouts swings and
roundabouts
yeah so there we go I think I I I just
think it's fair to say that the world
has
been science fiction really I think is a
window into the into the world we live
in because I think we can talk about the
positive we can talk about the best and
the worst of humanity through a metaphor
and I think that's why we love it so
much because we can actually do these
have these conversations in ways that we
can't in other media and that's one of
the reasons why I think science fiction
has
influenced the world that we live in in
in uncountable ways um it's seeped into
our souls and end well a lot of Geeks
love sci-fi and then they go and build
stuff so it's it's going to have been a
massive influence so secular monk has a
really good take on
all um we should be worried about the
future I mean you know it's I mean we're
wrecking the planet our society is too
concerned about arguing over cultural
issues that ultimately do not matter
science fiction is a way to show how it
could be that's exactly true you know
it's uh we're so worried about you know
the Bible verses that the Kardashians
are reading this week and
really well we've had how many
hurricanes are in the Atlantic right now
I mean I've lost track you know uh I
think uh Western uh Canada is still on
fire we're just not talking about it
because other places are on fire uh
we're talking about the flooding we're
talking about the insane heat waves
we're talking about you know water
disappearing from where it used to be
for tens of thousands of
years and the the things we're supposed
to we should be worrying about that we
can easily fix we just not because oh my
God I saw two girls kissing at the
Burger King it's the end of the world
gez at the Burger
King there was two chicks kissing at the
local Burger King and I it didn't ruin
my day I'm just saying it didn't ru ruin
your day that would be that would perk
my day right up I about to say I'm going
to Burger King in 20 minutes now yeah it
did not ruin my day at all there was
there was no there was no ruination by
observing two girls you know kissing in
the Burger King it was just a peo chi
come on chance offer anything I did that
was yeeha hotg give me some
sugar yeah wrapped up in that kind of
[__] right you know we're I mean I
live on the border of United States
Mexico you know you look on TV you you
expect that tens of millions of people
hoarding across the border into New
Mexico and it's just not
true there are them on the news I mean
it's the border is 45 minutes from here
I go down I'm in El Paso all the time
and it's
just there's tourists you know what the
biggest C okay so there's this one
Crossing at pedestrian bridge going from
El Paso into war as Mexico do you know
what most of the people on are it's old
[__] like me crossing a bridge to go to
thees in Mexico to buy dirt cheap
Pharmaceuticals and then coming back we
go down get our 90day supply come back
all as well we are the ones invading
Mexico old old farts like me way
around the can was it the Canadian Prime
Minister when he saiding um he come out
and said we're going to we're going to
build a wall because we're sick of the
Americans coming over here and getting
all the pharmacy and cheap booze and
stuff and then pissing off back to
America so maybe we should be thinking
about building a war I can't we should
be sealed off yeah but um as the problem
is I think there's a lot of division in
the United States at the moment it's
really pointless challenging and L of it
is pointless when did a bunch of
Christians Stop Believing in th love thy
neighbor and that you know that
actually that we should like forgive and
stuff and things like this and when
did Christianity become so angry and
people it always seems to be people that
they're Harden Christians God is in my
heart and but they're angry about
everything and I'm pretty sure Jesus was
only pissed off if somebody's rights
were being trampled on or if somebody
was being taken advantage of other than
that he seemed pretty yeah the only time
he was really angry is when the bankers
were in the
churchly I'm not relig it seems fair to
just put it on one religion it's
everybody whether you're religious not
religious doesn't care doesn't matter
what you believe who you believe in
what everyone I mean that's that's true
you know I mean organized religion
really doesn't have a great track record
oh no it doesn't I'm not trying to keep
up for it but everyone's busy yeah I
mean in America Christianity is the uh
has all the political power that's what
that's the only reason I'm bringing up
Christianity because at the moment it
seems to be
very loud Americans banging their chest
for for for
Christianity um terrified of everything
and hating everything and it just seems
to be but it is a very loud minority I
think I'd like most Christians don't
they they believe in what they believe
in but they don't use it to batter
somebody else just seems to be the sort
of aoud minority at the moment they seem
to want to batter everyone else and
don't get me wrong it's the same for
every religion on the plan it there is
always going to be that secular that
that that very angry side to it any any
group you're going to get even political
parties you know you get the left and
the right wing within every party and
you know hope the conservatives and
we're like oh God the lefties are coming
and the bulk of the the conservative
party are very sensible thoughtful
people but there's a loud minority that
make the whole party look bad the labor
part is the same there's a very loud
right-wing you've got the same the
Republicans and the Democrats you know
yeah but you're tossing an entire
religion into one category of
politicalization as well I'm from the
Bible Belt nobody talks or acts like
that there they haven't my entire I know
I'm not old but 25 years of living no
one talks like that I come from 120,000
person Town not the biggest not the
smallest I've I've been to the 300
person cities three million person
cities all throughout Texas all
throughout the South every St there no
one talks like that that is a character
characterization made by news people on
both sides it's
it's loud minority though then that's
what I'm trying to say but it's not even
the loud minority it's louder than
perception of it I guess going
back I just don't want to make you think
that I'm sort of dising some or anybody
like it's what I'm trying to say is when
you've got a loud minority
shouting the ception is that it it
covers that whole group
because they're the one shouting all the
time and that that's going to color a
whole whole group regardless of I I I I
know exactly what you're saying yeah but
but but to single them out I think is
where I'm I'm just like let's not single
them out because there's a loud minority
on the other side that are doing the
exact opposite but the exact same thing
and they're just as bad the world every
group on the planet is the same the only
reason I mentioned Christianity is
because we were talking about America
yeah and anyway let me go back to
something uh popcorn power said if Jay's
perception of anger Christian Americans
were true they would not be gay marriage
legalized in the United States uh
Clarence Thomas in his decision to
Outlaw
abortion um in his uh opinion he wrote
those are the things that are next and
there is uh the next thing that's that
they the uh we call them the Christian
Taliban here in America those the out
the the really loud out people that
really do not practice anything written
on the in the sermon of the mouth is to
get rid of birth control not just birth
control for you know emergency
contraception but birth control period
those are that's already working its way
through the courts in several States
we're already Banning books that talk
about slavery you know we're we're you
know we're Banning books we're Banning
classroom instruction that talks about
slavery and this is from the the the
Christian the the far right- ring
militarized Christian Movement in
America
uh and gay marriage is on the uh the
rights agenda to get rid of I mean that
was in Clarence Thomas's
statements from from the bench that's on
that's on the agenda there was when gay
marriage was legalized the United States
several States then moved to make it
illegal and then my understand is the
Supreme Court then had to step in and
actually
ban states banning gay marriage so they
had to actually step in and go no you
can't um it's is there a similar problem
going on with it that that's basically
what's going on with abortion at the
moment isn't it that basically states
are creating laws to they can't they're
not allowed to ban abortion but what
they have to do instead is make it so
difficult to get an abortion it's
virtually illegal no they can they can
totally ban
abortion they couldn't aren't they
looking at actually overturn in Rover's
Wade at the moment they did R Wade is
dead there you go
dead but yeah I think when all this
started now there's always you know a
radical Christian Movement in America
that started after uh the Civil War and
the that was really manifested in the
KKK the kclas clan which saw ra um they
were just pissed off that blacks were
free you know America's greatest sins
are included in its founding documents I
mean we talk about we we legalized
slavery in the Constitution we outlined
our first national enemy as Savage
Indians I mean genocide is right there
in our founding documents and so a lot
of those people that signed those
documents were
Christian and they love them some
slavery so in in terms of
um uh not all I'm not saying this is all
Christians but the people the the land
owners the people that could uh
legislate this stuff uh definitely you
know did so because of Jesus but when it
really became when when political power
really at least in modern times really
came to a head in terms of religion I
think that's at the feet of n Gingrich
the house Speaker during the Clinton
Administration really really sought
Division and militarization of a relig
religious movement to change uh secular
America and I think it started with new
gingr yeah I know what that comment is
about and I hate you um can we ban klopp
please sorry de just scor about man
united so we've lost last minute of the
game um I think the point is about we
talking about loud minorities and blah
blah blah I think
cruel greedy spiteful people will always
find an excuse to be cruel greedy and
spiteful and um and whether that
be a religion capitalism the word woke
whatever it is they want to hide behind
they will always try to
justify being cruel greedy and spiteful
and it doesn't matter what color you are
what religion you are what whatever it
is they will find that thing and I think
there's a big big problem in America
though that there are a few cruel
spiteful people that are hiding
behind whatever flag it is they're
hiding behind that and and they always
will and um we have to but we have to
try to fight against that where we
can because most people aren't cruel
spiteful and
greedy absolutely true absolutely true
but you unfortunately get a small number
of people that just seem to be louder
than the rest of us and what is it what
was I saying the term when does evil win
is when good men fail to act and that
far too often far too people just don't
stand up when something's being done
wrong you know
like anyway well this conversation went
way off base I mean yeah what what you
been watch we've got five minutes
anybody been watching anything good this
week I've only been watching starget
Atlantis so I'm out of this
conversation Walking Dead start walking
dead
yeah uh foundation and uh Stargate
hg1 oh you start we're hit deep in the
ory
now see I say I was think I still was
watching D Atlantic I could not
understand why the um Apollo didn't have
um energy
weapons um because surely the whole last
season of sg1 the 304s had energy
weapons and that was only like the dead
and the you know but they had energy
weapons and then we sent we so the
Apollo was built and launched at the end
of um Arc of Truth was the first time we
saw the Apollo and then they immediately
sent it to the Pegasus
Galaxy the the the least armed vessel in
the
fleet off sense to me at all I don't
understand it um but I suppose they had
to from a storyline point of view they
couldn't be too powerful straight away
or we would just battered the um
the the um space vampires
anyway um but anyway how about you
Harris what you've been watching this
week what you seen in the cinema sir
well uh not much in the cinemas I have
seen one new movie this week because
there there equalizer 3 was really the
only big movie out and I haven't seen
the second half of equalizer 2 so I need
to catch up a little bit so I didn't go
see that I did see
bottoms which have yall heard anything
about this movie at all it is the
funniest movie of this year bottoms it
is titled bottoms it is these two
lesbian girls they weren't in Burger
King don't
worry
correct it was the funniest freaking
movie I've seen this entire year maybe
in a long time it the the the premise is
these two girls uh they're both lesbians
they're in high school probably later in
high school they they have these couple
girls that they really like and you know
they're just too scared to talk to them
they're best friends so they're not like
in a couple or like a relationship or
anything they're just best friends uh
and I guess they bond over being lesbian
and all these different things y
yada but lesbian I'm lesbian let's be
friends let's be friends but they've
been best friends for a long time uh
it's really funny Punky Johnson is in
there just for a little bit and she
plays their lesbian Yoda is what they
call
her it's the funniest thing in the world
the the premise of it is these two girls
feel
ostracized so
they they are trying to find a way to
get the attention of the two girls they
do like Manchester United just had
something bad happen
um oh God no uh but but okay so the two
girls they they're they're working up
their schemes and their scheme to get
the girls attention and you know they're
going after like the two most popular
girls in school like the one girl's
dating the the football quarterback and
the other ones the girl's best friend
kind of deal the the premise of the
movie is to get those two girls
attention they start a fight club a
female Fight Club in the school oh my
God and the teacher they get to become
their like sponsor is Marshon Lynch the
old football player beast mode the the
beast mode that guy uh and it is
the I I just I couldn't stop laughing
for two hour or hour and a half it was
great it was great I had no idea what to
expect going into it
and I've thought about it every minute
since it's been great yeah if there was
a film about lesbians I think about it a
lot afterwards as well not for the
reasons it's more like some
dismemberment and a lot of other things
it's it's a very en enjoyable film it's
not what you expect it to be ever I saw
somebody talking about this a few weeks
before it came out actually they're
saying this is the strangest film they'd
ever seen and I'm thinking this been
some pretty strange films go with
anything by W tati before Ragnarok and
they strange [__] is
this is this what is this in the
theaters or or is it on it's it came out
on Thursday oh my God and it is so good
y'all I mean I recomend go on my list I
could it's a little independent film it
might not be at every theater but it's
at enough and it is it's just it's
hilarious if Frank versus Russia made
you laugh this will this will make you
laugh um uh besides that what we do in
the shadows finished and that it
finished perfectly uh it's not the
season I guess and then only murders in
the building also had an amazing episode
this week
Andy yeah good my favorite show the show
my favorite show live at the moment like
like new show sort think it's my
favorite show I love only
murders all the
way we're starting to yeah yeah it's
it's brilliant it's just it's not like
laugh out loud funny but it just makes
me just smile but um we're starting to
now see the impact of the strikes that
actually there's nothing really coming
out it so so the cinema it's still we've
still been getting a steady stream of
movies like you said equalizer 3 I'm
really looking forward to it it's had a
really good weekend um is it Labor Day
for you guys you just said Labor Day is
that the holiday you've just had it's
Labor Day oh so it's the it's like the
third biggest Labor Day weekend ever or
something for for equalizer 3 there's
some record like that anyway so I mean
it's done really really well um and I
and I think it'll be great but after
this there's not a lot of movies or new
TV show coming out we're now going to
start getting the bite of this strike
that's that might go on for at least
another six
months and that's just just makes me
more sad yeah everything's being pushed
back um what was it the Daredevil series
and another series on Echo no no not
Echo Iron Heart Iron Heart can clearly
take out the list they just they just
give up putting it back they just took
them out so um it really is
now we're going to start seeing the
fight and um I don't think I think
there's been enough support behind the
strikes but when there's actually
nothing on the tally and there's nothing
on the
T now hopefully we'll start actually
seeing people really getting starting
get P people surely people are going to
start getting pissed off at some point
you g just give them what they want for
the love of God one thing I've noticed
is uh events you know movie events
coming back to theaters like a uh what
is it the re-release of interstellar on
IMAX is coming back to the theaters um
Taylor Swift oh my god oh yeah she oh
yeah you know the the the live show in
the theaters well that's going to
increase you AMC's profit certainly I
mean you saw her her pre-sales beat out
Deadpool I think Deadpool 2 had the most
uh number of pre-sales before any any
movie ever and Taylor Swift just beat
that out moop the floor with Deadpool
and so I'm starting to see a lot of
those term of you know in the trailers
you know alternative events that's just
not a Flatout movie and it'll be it'll
even if the strikes ended tomorrow that
that that's going to be us for the next
six months because it'll take at least
three to four months for the studios to
get going again and then never mind
getting anything into production
pre-production post you know all these
sort things so yeah getting score
written
we're all screwed are the are are the
composers and musicians are they on
strike also for uh soundtracks or is it
still
no some there's been some stuff that
there's been some like um solidarity
stuff going on but not
particularly
um said that they might spread it
through to games and things haven't they
as well cause it cause more problems
that could be huge I noticed that Indies
independent film makers are really I
mean they've already agreed to the SAG
after uh issues and they're the ones
that's I think it's a good play for them
because they you know they pay the
writers and everybody what they need you
know guarantee the rights of the uh
actors and now they're gonna be the only
things in the theater because the big
guys are just can't get off the pot so
to speak I mean they're just still stuck
in this mentality of not paying the
creatives so it's like what's his name
driver you know yeah he there he had
this announcement there was this
independent production he was doing that
was okay with the unions because the the
production company said oh yeah [__]
yeah we'll agree no problem and they're
going to be in the theaters and Disney
kind of won't have anything new for
quite some time I think it's genius move
on the Indies good for them
anyway come something sooner other than
later
right let's call it a day chaps so thank
you so so much um I'm massively
dehydrated and I need to go and lie down
let's go all the time you need a gallon
of
water see why when you watch the video
tomorrow you'll see why I'm struggling a
little bit today oh and then I went cup
and started drinking after this walk
that nearly killed me so um yeah just
one long list of cock-ups but thank you
so much guys as always absolutely
brilliant chat um we'll try to talk
about some a bit more fun than so Jade
did your butt plug coming in mail this
week you said the SRA logo right well he
said he got the sparkle Vader on order
I'm just wondering if it came problem
was Matt designed our logo and it's
really pointy so that's another reason
why I'm quite oh my God it's the butt
plugs in the logo now yeah so I gotta so
subversive I love him
no can we never mention book plugs on
this channel again
sure more tutorium on him no more butt
plugs did you see on Instagram that uh
in in chess news that yes he's allowed
back he's been cleared to play he got
vibrator has been cleared to play he's
cleared
out oh for the love of God right guys
Matt muted and ran off he's like I'm out
done we're done we're done we're out of
here um Captain cman you are late so
that's not my fault um go back and start
watch it from the
beginning the caveman thank you so so
much made of salt oh because you're
dehydrated well do you have a salt rock
but oh no never
mind not GNA happen not going to happen
no oh
man I think we're we're stuck with the
butt plugs right so I am going to
do need some moisturizer down there I'm
just saying yeah anyway guys thank you
so much Matt we'll see you next week sir
Harris thank you so much stormmy bear as
always you've been a legend Saye
everybody
bye bye guys see you
later
[Music]
does your butt plug have
[Laughter]
United